welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and with the
marble Brazilian Comic Con panel just
dropping a whole host of new
announcements on the future of the MCU
it's time to break down everything we
know about the upcoming slate throughout
this video I'm just gonna be going over
the full panel and discussing everything
that you need to know about what was
said and how it will play into the
future of the universe there may be some
spoilers here so if you want to go into
the upcoming films and TV shows as blind
as possible then I highly suggest that
you turn off now without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for click
in this video now let's get into our
breakdown of the marbles see cxp panel
I think it's called CC XP Comic Con XP
Comic Con experience yes just give all
this ok so the panel opened with the
first official on screen look at
elizabeth Olsen and Paul Bettany and the
upcoming show one division as expected
the show is drawing heavily from 1956
coms like Leave It to Beaver be vit 2
livre I don't know basically all of the
shows that make kids say okay boomer
well hey when they say okay boom oh
really winds me up I don't know why it's
pathetic really anyway it's kind of
clear from this that Wonder has created
her own sort of pocket dimension a
Pleasantville if you will that allows
her to live there with a long-lost love
and basically have the life that she
should have had the show is going to tie
heavily into Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness and this little
look suggests that the madness is going
to be one day who creates her own
alternate realities which after they are
likely destroyed at the end of the
series sends her mad like the multiverse
of madness you can't you can't call a
woman mad these days can you that's a
very old Knightley's reference on
british TV if anyone gets that yeah
thank you
I don't know if my theory on the whole
multiverse of madness thing is right but
that's what I will guess we also learn
that it's filmed in a hospital and
school over the last couple of days and
I think that the latter could be that
their children wicken in speed or
attending there as they're said to
feature in the series and yet this
is gonna be huge fanservice when they
appear basically they do need to go to
school so yeah that would be a great way
to introduce them anyway this is
definitely a ping the Tom King vision
graphic novel and yeah I'm really
excited for it I would have loved to
have seen some footage but yeah they're
just they're just not showing it much as
we'll get into the panel yeah they kind
of hold everything back this was then
followed by a big Black Widow
announcement and discussion on stage in
which Kevin Feige kind of went through
the ins and outs of the plot discussing
the setting of Budapest and at the end
of the show he also showed a black widow
poster which is sort of keeping in line
with the new look and design of the ones
that we've seen so far during this talk
the audience actually got to see an
extended Black Widow trailer which I'm
guessing we will see soonish but for the
moment it was just exclusive to
comic-con now apparently it didn't
really add all that much extra plot than
what we already know however it did sort
of flesh out the action scenes a bit
more and also showed the comic-con
footage that had taskmaster flipping the
car that Black Widow was driving in and
then approaching her Kevin Feige said
that they would be showing more of
budapest more of the plot and that's
what they came to do and I guess they
did it now we do know that elements of
Black Widow will actually take place
before the events of Iron Man and this
is why general Ross was the Aged for the
teaser that we got basically the film is
gonna show elements of Budapest and the
infamous mission that Widow was a part
of that it's pretty much been named
dropped in every single film that she's
ever featured in and this could be where
the rumored Hawkeye cameo happens and it
could also show how her family is formed
in that film that she ends up teaming up
with not too much extra here well yeah
they gave away copies of the posters to
some audience members so good stuff I
guess
following this with some footage from
the Eternals that was shown that then
got cut into a trailer we don't have a
full description of this just yet but we
can't expect this in the next couple of
days so yeah keep an eye out for that
now they kind of went through the cast
again which they've done at other Comic
Cons in the past and overall I'm still
very unsure about this film like I am
excited to see a movie in the cosmic MCU
once more but I really also want to see
it set up the events of the MCU as it's
rumored to do I'd love it if we got like
a young Danis in it or Ronan the
you know just something extra Easter
eggs wise that would really pull us into
the film we'll see how all that happens
but going forward the Eternals are
clearly gonna be a big part of the
Marvel Universe so like it I love it
you're gonna have to get used to it
personally I am really excited for it
but you know I'm going in with tempered
expectations Black Widow is probably the
film next year that I'm most excited for
but hey this could knock it out the park
as we know you know Marvel movies can do
that whether it's guardians of the
galaxy door act and rock whenever they
tackle something in space it always does
really well and yeah I am I am excited
to see it just you know toning my
expectations back a bit on top of this
we also got two images from the upcoming
Disney Plus show the Falcon and Winter
Soldier that showed images from the
actual show itself it kind of looks like
Bucky is taking charge in these and it's
weird seeing Sam take a backseat to it
as hey I really want to see him step
into the role of Captain America I mean
who doesn't right look Bucky is an
old-age pensioner Sam don't take that
from him I know you should respect your
elders but you know take some charge my
man what's going on anyway that was
pretty much the entire panel and it
closed up after about 45 minutes now I'm
guessing if you're watching this video a
bit like me you kind of like who was
that it like I wasn't sure whether I was
actually gonna cover this as it's a bit
hit-and-miss and there's not really much
to go on but you know I promise people
for the last week in the comment section
and all that sort of thing that I would
definitely be going over it so I felt
like I needed to cover it now we did
have a lot of rumors earlier in the week
about what was going to be announced at
the panel and I'm really really glad
that I didn't just jump on there and
because a lot of them did seem like
clickbait like I see I've seen a lot of
youtubers posting that the x-men and
Fantastic Four line it would be
announced and yeah personally I just
couldn't see that happening at the
moment I'm really really trying my best
not to report on fake news so seeing
channels post things like Deadpool 3
confirmed to be announced at CC XP and
it's gonna be the full phase 5 lineup it
just seemed a lot like wishful thinking
and I hate when people do those kind of
videos especially if they know that
they're not true as they build a lot of
hope up and ultimately eat a
disappointment I have done videos in the
past
similar to that that have turned out to
be untrue and overall at the time I did
believe that they were gonna happen and
when it turned out that they weren't it
really did leave me feeling like I'd let
a lot of people down and it's not good
in the long term just getting views on
stuff that turns out to be basically
another one of Mysterio's illusions so
yeah stop that you naughty naughty
youtubers there was no way that the
entire phase 5 panel was gonna be
announced that this thing as expected
the show itself was a lot more scaled
back and I kind of think that if you
went into it like I did with tempered
expectations you're not gonna be that
disappointed however if you went into it
thinking that this was gonna be the
phase 5 lineup Wolverines gonna be cast
Hugh Jackman is back you know the it's
just it's gonna let you down so I can
see why a lot of people are calling this
a waste of time you know there was
nothing on the Fantastic Four x-men and
so on overall you know at this point in
the MCU I personally think it'll be a
long time before we get any big
substantial announcements because yeah
they did just announce their entire
lineup a couple of months ago so no
doubt they'll be holding off on things
until there's a bit more breathing room
down the line like you don't want to
announce your entire five-year plan when
people are happy with just a two-year
one and hey Marvel do not have to show
their hand at this point as their head
of everyone else also a scene on reddit
that people were disappointed that they
didn't announce Deadpool 3 as Ryan
Reynolds was actually at this comic-con
but yeah like that they can just hold
these announcements back for as long as
they want because you know it keeps that
hype train going there's absolutely no
point in dropping everything for the
next 5 years at this point
anyway that's everything you need to
know about the panel obviously I'd love
to hear your thoughts about what was
announced and if you're looking forward
to the future of the MCU comment below
and let me know and if you enjoy this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our full
breakdown of the black widow trailer
which would be linked at the end we go
over everything that you need to know
about the film and give our thoughts and
how the movie looks and the plot leaks
about its story it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
and if you want to come chat to me after
the video then make sure you follow me
on twitter at definition whitey or head
over to my discord server which should
be linked in the description below we
drop videos on there early so if you
want to see stuff before anyone
and that's the best place to be it's
free adjoining we have an awesome
community so hopefully I see you over
there very soon we're also giving away a
free copy of the marble phase 3 part 2
boxer on blu-ray which contains Black
Panther infinity war and Game Captain
Marvel and more and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
to the channel and leave your thoughts
on the panel in the comment section
below
the winners gonna be chosen on the 15th
of December and the set will be shipped
out from then to ever gets the prize
it's the best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best now see you next
time take care
peace
[Music]